want to review you yes as a person yeah
let's start off with your eyes
marco did you know that your eyes can
distinguish between 2.7
to about seven and a half some people
say 10 million because i'm one of his
fans i'm a muslim
one of his fans and most of the gadgets
that i buy i review his stuff i watch
his videos before i go and purchase it
check out our sponsors nature's blend
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah i've
got a bit of a cold i'm not feeling well
so i might be coughing and then don't
worry it's not contagious before i start
i want to praise god almighty the most
merciful the most trust or praises glory
and gratitude
belong to him why do we have gratitude
to god before i come to the whole marcus
brownlee thing which this video is
specifically for him because i'm one of
his fans i'm a muslim
one of his fans and most of the gadgets
that i buy i review his stuff i watch
his videos before i go and purchase it
now
why do we have gratitude to god we have
gratitude to god not because of what he
does for us so now i'm thankful to
marcus
brownlee why because he has helped me to
make the right choices tomorrow i saw
that now i can press
record on my phone but my new watchdog
say hello my bad
please guys i got a discount as well
from um sister mayor leblanc so he works
at apple got me a discount and i use
this for fitness and a variety of other
stuff hundreds it's one of the biggest
gifts um
my wife bought me may allah so please i
love my bag i really appreciate that but
anyways marcus brownie enabled and
helped me to make the right decision
the phone that i have to the watch that
i'm wearing to be the other gadgets that
i wear i watch his stuff and i'm
grateful for him now why am i grateful
for
something he's done in return and that's
usually how it works sometimes you know
someone does you a favor but when it
comes to god we are thankful to god
because of who he is and not what he
does for us
what he does for us we can't count and
that's the reason why i'm doing this
video for brother marcus
brownlee yes and i hope he watches this
the reason i'm doing it is brother and
sisters is because
he's helped me make the right choices
and the prophet peace be upon him has
told us the one who's not thankful to
the people are not thankful to allah to
god almighty and we do not believe god
is a man human being
because god says in the quran
there is nothing like allah yes there's
nothing like him
and he is all hearing and all seen
that's the reason why i'm doing this
video just to thank him this is the
reason why i'm doing this video and i
want to just give him an invitation to
islam but before i do that i want to
share some things with him which i
believe will be profound now marcus
brownlee like i said before he has this
amazing studio he's got the top notch
quality cameras
um in a studio and he does review of
text of apple's galaxy
samsung galaxy you name it all the
gadgets yeah ps5
even cars yeah so it's good so before
you buy a product you review it now
something that i wanted to do was a bit
different now has as marcus brownlee
reviews gadgets i thought to myself what
is the most
best amazing gadget should we say that
has reached a power excellence the
pinnacle
in our creation we want to review you
yes as a person
yeah now let's start off with your eyes
marco did you know that your eyes can
distinguish between 2.7
to about seven and a half some people
say 10 million
not 100 no not a thousand million
different colors
your eyes yes your very eyes mark your
eyes can distinguish between
nearly 10 million colors your eyes are
256
mega pixels that doesn't even come
across any other gadgets that you review
think about it because i'm trying to get
somewhere here think about that for a
second our fingerprints that we use that
one does not match the other yes as
human beings seven billion people our
finger fingerprints are distinguished by
40 different characteristics our iris in
our eye
guess what our fingerprint has 40
different characteristics
yeah and none of us match another our
iris has
256 different
256 different different characteristics
isn't that
amazing let's carry on your your nose
your nose can smell
ten thousand different smells ten
thousand
you can hear 350 different sounds yeah
your tongue can
your tongue can taste millions maybe
billions of different flavors fruits and
god knows what else
that's your tongue your eye and your
nose
that's it that just just that's just
this part of your body yeah that's how
complex it is yeah
your liver what's the drop of your liver
your liver analytics mulch releases
protein to cause blood clots to stop
bleeding it cleans your blood
you eat carbs body breaks down the carbs
to glucose
and your liver grabs glucose and stores
it as glycogen
and your liver breaks down the glycogen
and release sugar into the blood
that sounds a bit like a laboratory to
me it's like a little factory going on
oh and it's the only organ the liver
that regenerates itself it can
regenerate itself
the kidney filters out 200 liters
of blood now i just wanted to give you a
few stuff not all i don't know
there's this your body is a mechanism
and a operation it's like a factory a
gigantic factory we don't want to go
into the dna
to the atoms to the cells it is a
profound profound creation now marcus
you're an intelligent man i don't know
you're an intelligent man i enjoy your
videos i'm one of your biggest fans i
genuinely enjoy your videos
i don't want you to give me a shout out
i don't want you to even mention me all
i want you to
genuinely do is really really think
about what i'm about to tell you
if all these gadgets that you review and
let's see for arguments say you have
never seen these gadgets
yeah and let me ask you a simple
question how do you know that the very
apple phones
that you review are are made now you
come and say to me
well that's easy i can go to the factory
what's the big deal
okay hold on a second let's suppose you
never visited an apple factory
let's suppose you know nothing about
apple one day
imagine somebody comes and says here's
this gadget
imagine there's no there's no gadgets
you're living in there
in the the astonish i don't know
whatever it may be here okay
the argument's sake do you believe that
apple
the phone that you have that you review
it's created
because you can go to the factory or do
you believe it's created
and designed and has a purpose these
three words
created has a design and therefore
um has a purpose you believe that
because of the design that you see
that's the most probable logical answer
because you would only believe that is
from
you would only believe it is created why
because of the design structure
because of the purpose it serves and
therefore that will point out to what if
there is design it requires a designer
if it's created it requires a creator
that is the reason why i want you to
really point i don't know if you believe
in god or not
i do not know but i would personally say
i invite you to look into islam
so that's the reason why marcus i really
wanted you to think about it and
look into islam i came to islam seven
eight years ago and i looked into
different religions as well
and there's many reasons why i chose
islam i'm just asking you if you don't
believe in a god to really question that
because you're somebody that from a
day-to-day
review these things and some of these
things that you review and you're
impressed by their camera quality you're
reviewing them with the very eye
that is more profound than the very
camera lens
that you're trying to review so as your
fan i wanted to give this video and send
this to you
and i hope that you can hopefully um do
some research into islam and i'm going
to finish off with this verse in the
quran which we recite nearly every day
yeah 70 times a day and i want you to
understand
what that is um and thank you if you're
watching this or if you've seen this
hopefully you've seen all your followers
um yeah so it goes with the following i
want to be like
here
belong to the to the lord of the whole
world
alhamdulillah
the most merciful the very merciful
malik
owner of the day of judgment buddha
guide us to the straight path of those
guides to the straight path
the path of those of whom you have
favored not of those who
have earned your anger and have gone
astray brother sisters
please send this to brother marcus uh
brownlee inshallah and hopefully he can
benefit from that he's helped me a lot i
want to thank him for that
uh and check him out inshaallah until
next time brother sisters assalamu
alaikum welcome to america
i'll bring you guys i'm bringing you
guys these videos but please it's your
job to get that message to him and
hopefully you can watch it
till next time goodbye let me press stop
now check this guys out
bye